hey what is happening samuel leeds here
and in this video i wanted to give you
the number one
ingredient to success the one
because everyone wants that one thing
right everyone just wants to know what's
the secret what's the thing
and and normally you know people say
there is no secret there is no one thing
it's a whole bunch of things hard work
knowledge skills discipline
all kinds of stuff but actually i've
been studying this real hard
i've been seeing successful people
i mean to begin with when i became
successful when i became successful
um to become successful i studied rich
people i studied people that were
succeeding and i thought
what is it about people that succeed and
people that don't
how can i learn the traits of the people
that succeed which i studied
but there's one big thing one thing
which which i learned and mastered and
that result would boom in the floodgates
opening for me
and me resorting and doing my first deal
my second deal my tenth deal
my 100th deal now doing millions and
millions of pounds worth of deals
and in this video guess what i'm gonna
be revealing that one thing
um also i've got a gift as well at the
end of the video so stick around till
the end it's only going to be a short
one
and don't forget of course to like the
video
subscribe even though i dress terribly
right now this i am so i need a shave i
need to gel my hair
i need to get um a decent t-shirt on the
reason i'm dressed terribly is because
um i'm having a rest day today's a rest
a rest day
um so today's a rest day but i still
thought i'd do a video i do a video
every single day
so what's that one thing okay what's
that one thing
well i've seen the one thing also with
my students i might do it do a training
program i've got two people
and they're sat next to each other and
they are
teamed up this is an example alastair
alice dead cunningham you probably know
him he's the most
probably the most successful deal
sourcer in the uk
he came down to a training program okay
and hit the training
his very first training program that he
did with me his partner
or the person that he was sat next to
and i got them partnering up doing
exercises
guess what she achieved nothing
and he became one of the most successful
deal sources
in the uk they had the same training
so what did they do different what's the
secret is the secret training actually
no
the secret is not training is it taking
action
nope is it willpower is it discipline
what is the secret well i'm gonna reveal
it right now the secret
is is what we call your
financial thermostat
your financial thermostat and what i
mean by that is in this room right now
the room is set for 23 degrees celsius
my wife is african she likes it hot
so she sets the temperature high 23
degrees now
if it's a cold day and the windows open
the fact i won't open the window
because it's kind of warm if i open the
window
okay in about 10 minutes the temperature
of this room
will probably have dropped to 21.
however
in time it's gonna end up back again at
23. it might be
if we have a lot of people over if we
have some guests and the rooms full
maybe we turn the fire on
it goes up to 25 but what's going to
happen is the thermostat
is going to readjust itself and
the thermostat is going to readjust
itself and the temperature is going to
go back
to what the setting of the temperature
the thermostat set for because that's
the setting
and in the exact same way you and i
have a financial thermostat
we have a financial setting we are
programmed to make to hold
to have a certain amount of money and
maybe you think whatever samuel talking
nonsense
well this is the truth and
the secret to success is figuring out
what your thermostat is
knowing what it is and then just
changing it so that if at the moment
your thermostat is to have 2 thousand
pounds in the bank
that's how much you're used to and
you're used to making 24 grand a year
that's your thermostat that's not my
thermostat it is because when you apply
for jobs you apply for jobs that are
about 24 grand
why would you not apply for a job that's
100 grand because
it doesn't feel right because you are
programmed to make a certain amount of
money
the lottery if you win the lottery
i mean i could give you a million pounds
right now in cash
you say go on then do it do it to prove
the experiment but what would happen is
in five years
you'd be in the exact same situation as
you are right now because that is your
thermostat
i don't have to give you a million
pounds to prove it because the lottery
has proved
it so figure out what your thermostat is
and change it on the spot
and and then what happened is everything
you start touching is gonna start
turning to gold
uh this is the truth this is the reality
i figured out what my financial
thermostat was and it was set for low
i'm from a working class background you
know no one around me in my family
my friends were millionaires so my
thermostat was set for low
i realized i changed it and then i got
rich
so that's the number one secret how do
you change it it takes a little bit of
time
i got a gift i did promise you a gift
the gift is
um i am running tomorrow
the property investors crash course
virtually and it's free
that's my gift and then next month on
the 21st of june
i'm running a live physical training day
and that's going to be in portsmouth
then i'm doing it again in swindon then
i'm doing it again in manchester
in leeds in birmingham in london i'm
doing a tour where i'm going to be
running a training day
teaching people teaching you how to make
money in property how to invest money in
property but more important
how to change your thermostat so if you
want to if you want to join me on the
training day guess what
it is free because today's a friday
every friday i'm always going to give a
gift
give back friday giveaway friday so
today that's the giveaway so you can
click on the link below and get
registered for the training
um and and and i think listen rather
than trying to
just make more money if you've got a
bucket and there's holes in it you can
keep putting water in it but it's gonna
keep leaking out
so stop working hard and trying to get
rich and all this stuff the other
fix your financial thermostat i'm happy
to help you do it
my name is samuel leeds i'll see you on
training get registered i can
i might see you tomorrow on the virtual
training or i'll see you next month
but either way get registered let's make
it happen thanks so much god bless and
peace out